if you're an adult in nevada you can get  the coronavirus vaccine booster shot now  18 and older doctors are worried about  waning immunity and a concern for those  who have already been vaccinated against  coronavirus so when you get your booster  shot you might experience some minor  side effects these might sound familiar  sore arm fatigue muscle weakness and  even headache  the side effects that we get are due to  that robust immune reaction but our  immune reaction is probably more robust  than it actually has to be to protect us  and not everybody feels those symptoms  the same way  so after you get your vaccine shot or  even the booster shot stay home take it  easy drink lots of fluids and take over  the counter pain medication if you need  it just to try and get through the  possible symptoms